jazz kids und herzlich willkommen zu
sein herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video wir sind heute zum ersten mal in
einem video auf manchen auf jump world
aber nicht alleine denn ich habe jede
menge leute bei wissen grad hier mit 15
leuten auf timo einer party alle 15 sind
auch auf meinem ps ich hab gedacht ich
mache so eine kleine community aufnahme
sagte hallo also er hat schon jede menge
leute hier unter einem fax auch dabei
vom team milram team und da hier das
wirklich ziemlich witzig ich suche jetzt
meine map raus wir spielen erst mal eine
map normal gucken wer da sich gut
schlägt und bei der zweiten map werden
wir uns gemeinsam hier mit dem ts
channel so natürlich ausdenken die dann
da spielen
okay leute ich hab mir ein paar
rausgesucht die mit sk gedeckt wurden
das ist die erste die für mich ist
deswegen nehmen wir die hier mal heißt
die sp von dsk confirmed wie läuft's bei
euch was am weitesten geht arbeiter
dabei alles gebraucht
ab sofort heißt die abkürzung zufällig
fleischpreisen client kann es sein kann
er musste gar nicht achja easy access
okay aber mit meinem text erkennt man
das gar nicht gut okay und ich kann es
schaffen ich kann erster sein und direkt
erster leider leider alles mal sehr gut
wenn wir jetzt natürlich eine challenge
machen dann müsst ihr wir müssen ehrlich
mitspielen
zum beispiel wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
machen das so weit runter wie es geht
drei aspekte leute ich würde sagen als
zweiter spieler so einen kleinen insel
jump ihr okay alles klar leute also wie
das rein auf inseldorf von ixia raketen
an alle elf auf 30 ehrlich leute schnell
runter auf 30 aussehen
ich glaube auch alles mit
viel einfacher auf ich weiß auch what
the [ __ ] wo geht's hier von einer leiter
aus weiter von der ersten acht plätze
die man sieht halt gar nichts
was ist hast ja man kann auch einfach
überhaupt nicht einschätzen ich fühle
mich als wenn ich so ohne bezahlt hätte
ich irgendwie die grünsten augen aller
zeiten
oder wie es wenig wie es die schnecke
von spongebob noch mal meine augen nicht
mehr in meinem kopf sondern so schülern
dreimal die milliarden mäßig what the
[ __ ] also ok und wo campus erreicht also
eigentlich ein etui 30 hat ungefähr das
schlimmste was der menschheit jemals
passieren konnte
ich überlege gerade ob wir uns alle
oder ob
nicht alle schnell noch mal den celli
world lautet eine runde mit allen
spielen oder gold machen lassen
eine christmas cooler wenn ich okay
leute gespielt jetzt noch eine runde und
wir haben uns gerade im ausgereiftes und
weise das geht auf meine kappe ich hab
mir aus gehabt dass wir doch einfach mal
eine runde mit einer kleinen zellen
spielen und wo ist der wunderschöne
animal crossing punkte
heute gab schon darüber nachgedacht ich
weiß ihr wollt mich jetzt alle verklagen
und umbringen den kann man schaffen ja
erlaubt die alle die gleiche richtung
wie ich ich sehe euch ganz okay okay
also wieder richtig augenkrebs m ach so
muss man muss halt sein
also kommt also wieder erreicht ich
wette du fährst und jetzt am spieß
extreme schäden an das im laufe des
videos zu sagen ja frei hacks alles klar
what the [ __ ] ich hab' ich hab's mir an
was da oben waren zu den sprung zu
schaffen hätte ich noch keinen sprung
geschafft habt ihr das gesehen man kein
mensch der welt gesundem verstand das
hätte gedacht dass man diesen spruch
erleben schaffen kann
hier um hier umgeht schnellster und ja
ich glaub ich glaube ich glaub ich bin
hier ja keine ahnung ich habe keine
ahnung
okay manchmal kalt 0 einschätzen muss
lang gehen soll
ich bin ich richtig ist falsch
wo ich sage mal richtig herr otte weiter
gehen
durch das ach so toll finde ich mal auf
dem papier zu recht x factor -moderator
locker hier lang
all diese betglocke schon ein bisschen
kürzer
dieser fakt dass zu sehen alte mutter
fragt wo bist du es geschafft alter
darauf darauf ein in die usa
heute wäre jetzt gerade 35 minuten
aufgenommen ich habe zwar etwas zusammen
geschnitten ich hoffe ihr seid nicht
daran gestorben bitte verklagt nicht
nicht bitte schickt mir keine
morddrohung mein leben ist schon schwer
genug leute bevor das video endet müssen
wir natürlich noch klären was passiert
wenn eine person das video zeigt was
bekommt jede person die das video läuft
und wir uns gerade im überlegt dass jede
person um quasi das leid wieder
gutzumachen passiert wenn euch das video
bisher angeschaut hat jede person die
das video like krieg eine erlaubnis mich
umzubringen
ja immer noch da noch dabei passt dass
du für euch ja auf jeden fall
das heißt jede person die dieses video
gesehen hat darf nicht einmal umbringen
aber nur einmal pro person
das heißt ich werde dann so zwei- bis
dreitausend mal sterben ich finds
verhältnismäßig auf jeden fall so dass
ein guter deal darauf einlassen
ja das war auch mein letztes video auf
jeden fall
ansonsten jetzt alle auf drei gemeinsam
chips ok 123
lala